you don't need to give somebody twenty
thousand dollars to learn any of these
skills it's a [ __ ] giant scam
period and all that knowledge is out
there for free
in podcasts and in books in your library
you don't even have to pay for it i
would say drug dealers are probably
more compassionate in that they don't
want their
folks to go bankrupt right like because
that would be bad for business
but i think that this group of people i
think they secretly enjoy
destroying people and taking their last
bits of money
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
coffeezilla another sunday special where
we talk about whatever i want today
we're talking to jason calcanis
he's the angel investor invested in all
a lot of the biggest companies you've
heard of including uber
a bunch of these others as well as robin
hood robin hood
let me say well front just tons of great
ones hey
you also are the uh you're a co-host of
the all-in podcast with chamath
and uh as well as david uh sax
yeah so amazing podcast you guys should
go
check it out bunch of best friends just
shooting the [ __ ] and today though
we're not talking about that we're
talking about the scumbags on clubhouse
you know how many tweets and emails i've
had to put on the burner because i've
been waiting for this podcast
i have been waiting for this
conversation i am a coffeezilla stan
okay hold on wait wait one second still
the intro
jason run the people down with what's
been going on it's a new audio
drop-in app called clubhouse and you've
been taking these guys to task but
you're like a real angel investor
and there's a real deal the guys who you
destroy
just so definitely on your podcast on
your youtube channel
the ones who you slice up you're slicing
them up
and i'm actually the real deal i invest
in companies
when they're just starting out i never
take any money from founders
i i wrote a book on angel investing
because i made a ton of money doing that
and it's 10 bucks or you can get it for
free
there's no course i do teach of course
angel university it's only for
accredited investors and we donate all
the money to charity
if there's any profits god bless you
jason wow hundred thousand we did a
hundred thousand in profits from that
angel university class and the reason i
teach those classes is because i want to
see more people
back founders i'm like the
in your world you have like the lex
luthors
and the and the in the super villain
absolutely yeah i am the
man of steel i am the dark knight yes
i am the actual real deal who actually
has succeeded and teaches a course
but the course is a hundred dollars or
three hundred dollars and basically it's
it's essentially free
when you're donated to charity it's
donated to charity because we just want
to make sure that those accredited
investors
actually show up for the course right so
we charge them 100 bucks or
when we do it in person i think we
charged 500 and that included a 300
dinner afterwards and like it just
literally we broke even on it right so
anybody who's charging you five thousand
dollars for a course or ten thousand
dollars
and they're nobodies who've never
accomplished anything you have to really
just
type in their name tai lopez jt fox
um brad whatever that guy's name was you
know them better than me
kevin david we could go down the list
and then just write
review or scam yep
at the end of their work name and then
or better business bureau and just look
at what people are saying
and if you take the moment to do that
you'll find all these
people i think in almost all those cases
who say these people are scam artists
who are trying to
grift their grifters they're growing
unfortunately the lowest economic
uh ladder of society and their
their goal is to take your money if you
if you're if you don't know what it
takes to be successful and you're trying
to improve yourself
they'll come to you with polished up
with all the trappings of success
unfortunately
we do live in like a a visual world now
where perception is reality you don't
need a background all you need
is a paid article in uh you know yahoo
news
from pr wire or whatever that's the scam
right
oh yeah fake stories using people don't
know this but there are pr
wires basically a way to put a press
release out but you put the press
release out
and these grifters all seem to have i
think we should deconstruct the grift
i think i was thinking about how we
could be the most helpful together
because this is kind of like a super
team right now it's like
you're like this superman i'm like this
batman we could make the justice league
here
i kind of feel like this is a a moment
where we could both
put our skills together to deconstruct
the audience how you're getting grifted
you know you're getting grifted i think
one thing is when you see the instagram
and somebody like tai lopez or jt
fox what they do is i think the
technique is
um the this manipulation technique this
influence technique
is to put themselves in proximity
to other powerful people so they get the
halo effect
and then to share the trappings of
wealth so
somebody like jt fox has all these
pictures of themselves
and notice jt fox had a picture himself
with julia roberts
with mark wahlberg mark wahlberg
and then other people who i think you
can pay them 50 grand or 25 grand
they'll show up for anything
okay you're so right but can i tell you
how right you are
okay tell me how right now how this
grift works in actual
practice with a specific example there's
a man named clint arthur that i
i exposed like about eight months ago a
year ago
clint arthur was a guy who basically ran
these groups
and he ran a fake harvard speech event
where he would go rent out a room in
harvard sell
out a bunch of tickets everyone in the
audience had bought a ticket to speak
but they're sitting in the audience as
if people are showing up to watch and
one by one they all go around the podium
speak at the podium it's all recorded
and then all of them put it on their
marketing material saying
i spoke at harvard talk about proximity
to
uh the credibility oh my god perfect
now you put yes you you basically are
co-opting harvard yeah so they all go to
harvard
and they spoke at harvard they were
asked
to speak at harvard you could say
harvard speaker
yep they got kicked they got kicked out
of harvard
they moved to west point they got kicked
out of there now they were speaking
during covet they were speaking at the
cnn center they went to the cnn center
not obviously he's not approved but they
rented out like the hotel room or
whatever
there's a cnn banner in the background
the guy's making
probably he cleared a million on sales
of this event okay so this is the
technique
people put themselves next to something
that we all respect in the world and
they hope to get that credibility by
association this is the technique
so let's put this technique as
credibility by association
but when you unpack it you realize they
have no affiliation
correct now compare and contrast this
i as an angel investor
was so lucky to have invested in so many
great companies
that stanford wrote a case study
on my ability as an angel investor and
networker
they actually wrote a case study so you
can go to the stanford business school
there is a case study written about my
career this
is how you are manifested by one of
these
you know business schools you either
went to that school you were a teacher
at that school or they wrote a case
study
right that's really the only way to be
affiliated oh yeah to be totally honest
but these
folks have hacked it or they'll pay for
it so
so sometimes you can cheat the
affiliation by paying for the
affiliation
as with the yahoo news thing i also knew
a guy who his dad was rich so he paid
this like
he was from india he paid a like
argentinian university a bunch of money
and they gave him an honorary
blockchain doctorate in blockchain so he
calls himself
dr evan luthra oh my lord and he was
pitching himself as this successful
investor okay the other thing is
these guys are like 27 i mean a lot of
them there are some older ones
so it's not a perfect indicator but a
lot of them are like hey i'm a
millionaire at
27 and you're like seven figure eight
figure nine figure businesses
this is the next piece okay so we have
the affiliation piece
the next piece is the lifestyle so they
take pictures of themselves
with fast cars oh yeah and so
tai lopez does he own all these cars or
does he just there's a lot of evidence
that it was they're rented
um it doesn't make much sense for them
to actually buy them out right because
they're marketing material
they literally right they're just
marketing to people who
think that wealth is a fast car
that wealth is not you know um
success in a business it's rather just
like owning things
like a you really what you have to
understand jason something that i've
realized after looking this stuff for
over a year
is that they know that most people
aren't
their target audience they're only
targeting people who
are vulnerable who either there's kind
of two types of people get scammed one
they're a first time scammed so they
haven't really been inoculated you could
say they don't have the the germ in them
they haven't been
they don't have the antibodies they
haven't been burned before they haven't
been looking for fresh meat naive people
fresh meat number two they're uh they're
sort of
repeat kind of they're people who get
stuck in a cycle of this
and this is where it gets much darker
where i've talked to people who've lost
twenty six thousand dollars thirty
thousand dollars i
am talking to one person right now the
story's still evolving
the doj might be involved
he may have lost and again is all
alleged 800 000
on coaching on materials on one of these
on one of this
it says it's a scam it's a confidence
scam and a lot of at the heart of a lot
of these things
is a comp confidence game so this was a
bitcoin thing there's also
uh but it all revolves around the same
cycle of
proof of like i'm a success i will make
you successful
if you just trust me if you put your
trust in me you put your money with me
right wow and you know it's really
interesting because what happened on
clubhouse and the way you and i
became uh aware of each other
was i was on clubhouse just answering
questions i
i make my email address public jason at
calicatas i'm jason on twitter
twitter.com
so i make myself available to any
founder who wants to pitch me i run free
events like founder university is free
250 people come to it it's free for
founders we do this because
we want to meet founders so we can
invest in their companies and we make
money over 10 years investing the
companies
now we don't make money off of selling
them a course founder dot university is
free
we do that to get deal flow we want to
meet the next uber or
robin hood or com or whatever it is and
we want to invest in the company and
then be aligned with the founder
right i saw these people jt fox and this
guy brad
and i looked them up and it turns out
they're answering questions they're
coaching people
they might have been a little racist um
or
you know um in how they approached it so
this kid jt got suspended
because people were complaining that he
might have been a little racist i wasn't
there for that instance
but i just said you know this is a scam
i can tell it's a grift
and i cuz i type the names of the people
and this one guy brad is doing
mlm cbd products so multi-level
marketing
of cdbd so that's like ripping that's
ripping the fabric of the scam universe
cbd
yeah yeah it's like what else are we
going to put in there coaching you on
how to do cbd
yeah of course of course just wait till
you find out about the courses
that are about how to sell a course
that'll really blow your mind well i
heard about this that there was a there
was this woman
i think her name was lauren in the room
and she the reason i got kicked out of
the room was
they brought me up as a speaker because
they know i'm notable
and she said well i'm charging you the
way you do this is you charge eight
thousand but then you discount it to
four you get people on the phone
you explain to them what you how you're
going to hold them accountable and i
said four thousand dollars
i said what qualifies you to charge four
thousand dollars for coaching and they
kick me out of the room
but then they brought me back and then
mchammer put me back on stage and i said
listen
four thousand dollars is a scam like if
you're a coach like why don't you just
charge
four hundred dollars an hour and if you
do one hour
and it really helped me maybe in two
weeks i'll pay you 400
again like no you got to get the 8 000
up front you got to do it
so this is one of the ways in which you
know if you're getting scammed
if you went to a therapist a personal
trainer a tennis coach
a chess coach whatever would they demand
you pay them twenty thousand dollars up
front for twenty weeks
or would they say i charge ninety
dollars a tennis lesson or
three hundred dollars to go to therapy
or a hundred fifty dollars for a life
coach
or whatever it is they would just charge
you procession of course these people
are not charging per session are they
stephen
no no no it's the it's the six week
whatever course and by the way because
they're all videotaped
it's free it's like so there's a
difference between courses in coaching
right
coaching you can justify a slightly
higher price but i agree it's like a per
session thing there's also courses that
are being sold
the course is there's literally a zero
cost except customer acquisition
right from ads the reason they charge so
much is because customer acquisition is
so high because the scam market is so
oversaturated with people
promising dreams to people but it's led
to this weird thing where you're like
learning the basics of like facebook ad
strategy
but you're paying four thousand dollars
to do it by the way
stephen all of that is for available for
free from facebook
and twitter they have their own youtube
videos and they are the people who are
it's this they're educating you because
they want you to use the secret to
facebook
to wild riches on facebook
you don't want to just learn facebook do
you want to learn the proven blueprint
to success
from a nine-figure earner by the way had
they become a nine-figure earner they
sold a course
that's the funny thing is a lot of these
guys they're earning things that they
say they
they're like seven figure order eight
figure earners you just go on clubhouse
tap on a bio
they're making they're claiming the
sales from the course
as how they're legit as their
entrepreneur so
here's what i realized they had these
bios i'm just going to read you one of
them
i don't know who ash gandahari is
but eight figure coaching business
and then you start reading these and
they all have eight figure seven figure
nine
figure and they have these giant long
bios about how they have
many businesses so the way i busted them
was i said to this guy brad
hagger h-a-g-e-r because somebody said
google him it's a scam and i googled him
and he had all these complaints you know
and people saying he had scammed them
out of money
and i realized he has this mlm so he's
on clubhouse talking and giving business
advice and then i think what they're
doing is this is their funnel
stephen to get you into an mlm course
where to get you to join their mlm scam
so i said to him
you have 47 businesses that are seven
eight nine figures tell me the name of
the most successful one so i can google
it and do a little research and maybe
there's a new york times story about her
profile they couldn't name one of their
businesses can i ask you something
because i feel like
i'm gonna really piss you off with this
one have you ever heard of the angels
and entrepreneurs summit
i did they basically took my book
and my investment in uber which was one
of the legendary investments
and they kind of crafted their whole
angel investor summit it was with one of
the sharks and neil patel
yeah yeah this is a disgusting scam
they basically i i was worried you were
going to be like yeah this is real legit
i was like please don't say that
this is super disgusting and they
basically cribbed
a lot of what i do and use that language
so you know i'm famous for making this
crazy and you know uber investment
you know that paid off thousands to one
right and that i got very lucky in that
regard to hit that but
it does happen in silicon valley every
you know five to ten years you hit
one of the outlier companies google
facebook right that's why that's why
you're investing
yeah that's what i do what i do right
you're hoping
that you hit one in a thousand well i've
hit that couple of times
it's very hard to do but it is possible
so i wrote a book about that with harper
collins business
uh the number one business publisher in
the world paid me a lot of money to
write that book
it's been translated into seven
languages the book is ten dollars i
explained to you everything i've learned
and
i i hope you buy it or i hope you get it
for free i hope somebody passes it on to
you and you get it from the library and
you get all that value
for ten dollars because i don't need
money from founders
or the public i make a lot of money as
an angel investor
you cannot there's no amount of money
that individuals could pay me
that could ever match an investment in
robin hood or uber or com
i mean does that make sense of course it
makes sense no no this is what i've been
telling my
audience this is what yes this is what
i've been telling my audience
is that if they had a better way to make
money they would just
do that they're doing what they do yes
they're preying on desperate people
because they
can't actually do what they say they can
do all these penny stock traders they
can't really trade
that's why they sell it all these i mean
it's so true it's like the saying like
those who can't do
teach but now it's those who can't do
charge two thousand dollars for a course
and then claim to be like the number one
guy in the world
i think i've been watching a bunch of
trading funnels recently i've heard
top trader in the world probably 10
times
in tin funnels and it's like you can't
say that
well i guess you can but it's a lie of
course well and i run something called
the angel summit and the angel launch is
the name of my investment fund launch
and we do the launch angel summit
so this scumbag neil patel who i know
because he used to be around the
industry
has never made any angel investments i
know of
i've never seen him on a cap table he
is um i think turned into a bit of a
grifter
um and i can tell you he's not talented
and he's kind of laughed at in our
industry
as like one of these affiliate kids who
does this like crazy affiliate summer
didn't he also copy a lot of stuff like
i think he was caught like
plagiarizing several times he's
plagiarized me a million times i think
um just in this effort and then they did
that thing where they hire the sharks so
the sharks from shark tank
mark cuban excluded because he's
actually rich he's actually rich yeah
but i think the other sharks are not
actually rich um
and he had the one guy um
do these videos on a yacht did you see
those oh yeah
yeah and i can tell you neil patel is
not rich and doesn't own a yacht
but they can rent a yacht but they
rented a yacht everything
which
okay so i don't know robert um he seems
like a nice guy
but damian and robert
seem to do any paid speaking that you
give them and if you give them fifty
thousand dollars they'll stand next to
you
and then what these scumbags do in these
courses and stuff
is they take them they get they give
them 50 000
then you as an unsuspecting person says
oh they're from shark tank they're
billionaires well they're not
billionaires or else they wouldn't need
the 50 000
speaking gig can i make it worse so not
only that they ran
uh robert ran a real estate
seminar gig which that's a gigantic scam
industry where it said like oh you're
gonna meet this guy blah blah blah
and then he wasn't actually at these
events and it's a boilerplate room where
basically they're just trying to sell
you on these like 20 000
seminars okay that's him damon john
is connected to raging bull who remember
the ftc guy
oh yeah he had a video endorsing that
guy because of course like you said
uh fifty thousand dollars they'll do
anything i don't think he's ever
said anything about that except to
basically block people who talk to him
about it
then damon john also got on a thing with
grant cardone and told
your video of that where they said take
the last thousand dollars we've got to
play it for people because they won't
believe it
they will not unbelievable they're like
if this person has only a thousand
dollars left and it's christmas
what do you tell them and damon john
says i tell them to buy it
buy the course for free and grant your
last thousand kids get no christmas
presents
me too i would tell them the same thing
that's who we're dealing with folks
that's who we're dealing with okay hold
on hold on hold on
this is so just and you caught them
editing their video and editing out the
christmas part
so even these scumbags have a limit
right oh yeah yeah
i gotta just find the clip real quick it
is so disgusting what i'm seeing here
and
i god bless you for doing this work i
have no idea what possesses you to do
this
i got pissed off i saw these guys and i
got so
angry that they set me on this year-long
quest i literally thought it would
take me a week to call all these guys
out and then you just find yourself
peering down the rabbit hole you're like
wait what is this
it's a weird phenomenon okay let's see
if we can find this clip ever could
hold on i gotta find the exact clip
unset like some of the aren't
like is i don't think kevin o'leary or
robert or
damon john actually have money because
if they did
why would they be on a rented yacht why
would they be selling schlocky courses
are they are they just
that desperate for an incremental 50k
now that doesn't make it they're making
a lot of money with this greg
he makes the money here and then he
plows it into real estate so it's like
it's like this is the this is cash flow
and then oh i can make my i can then
invest it into like real things and then
launder my reputation
i call it reputation laundering because
they're taking money
by ways that most people would consider
scummy or scammy
or distasteful and then they plowed into
things that most people would consider
legit like tai lopez is in the process
of trying to do this and i'm not going
to let him
he's investing in pier one right he's
doing a bunch of like things he's got a
bunch of
but where the money comes for nothing
right yeah yeah okay so anyway here's
the clip you through this entrepreneur
sales cures all sales cures all right so
if you're down to your last thousand
dollars this this offer today is 9.97
grant cardone.com for it's like a shark
okay yeah you're down a guy's sitting
there right now
watching this and i got my last grand
dude and i got christmas coming
should you spend it on this absolutely
i'll tell you the same thing i'll tell
you why oh so brutal
so brutal they literally would take the
last thousand dollars out of mom's purse
oh yeah
out of dad's water oh yeah take it take
that last thousand
the kids get no presents coal in their
stockings
don't pay the heat though just take your
last thousand and give it to grant
cardone i guess what you get for that
you get a course or a book an e-book i
don't know you get it you get you get
damon john's e-book
you get damond on demand which is like
his stupid course or whatever and then
you get a growth 10x growth con
guess what that is jason it's a pitch
for more stuff
so you're gonna go there broke and then
they're gonna go
hey you got a credit card
you got it yeah hey you got can you
swipe
this is this is actually a famous tactic
where in the back of the room
hey nobody's watching maybe we'll call
the bank with you maybe we'll uh you
know there's a lot of people who do this
so they first make you get broke they
get you to come to a free seminar
then they get you to do a hundred
dollars then they get you to do six
hundred dollars
then they get you to six thousand right
it's like they're boiling the frog
yeah and you just go people i mean
does tony robbins fall into this
category
because there are people who i know who
go to tony robbins seminars
it's a week it's five thousand dollars
which that's
in our industry a tech conference that
might be what a tech conference calls
but then they pay 10k
where they do personal consulting it
seems like a lot of these folks
kind of took the tony robbins
archetype and then they're kind of
rebuilding it as like cheap tony robbins
yeah so like deep versions like a poor
is it tai lopez and
they're sort of man tony robbins yeah
but what i can tell you is that like
i recently so i do this thing now where
i used to just analyze
the marketing but now i'm also like some
of these guys i'll go through their
course
and then i'll also talk about what's in
the course
so i have the cape knowledge business
blueprint which is tony robbins new
course
right he sells it for i think two
thousand dollars somewhere in that range
um anyways so during one of the little
modules
he's talking about you know selling your
business selling your knowledge
so he's teaching you maybe how to sell a
course
okay so he's teaching you this
they talk about how many people they
have in the program jason
they have something like i'm forget
blanking on the number i think it's like
13 thousand people or twenty thousand
people
you come to find out that they've made
tens of millions of dollars
off an online course that cost them
after production
zero dollars besides customer
acquisition
to make so the question is why wouldn't
tony just put it out on his website
listen i i
also don't really have that big of a
problem with like you want to go hear
the hura ra
there might be some value in that but
what's the value in like spending two
thousand dollars
to make tony richer and to make dean
graziosi richer
versus oh maybe we should just like give
this knowledge out for free because
we're trying to help people right
and the people who look up to us like
yeah some of them are successful
but a lot of them are like in desperate
straits who resonate with tony's life
story of being like broke and destitute
so
why not just release the information or
like you
maybe say 100 bucks just to maybe get
some commitment
but then like give it to charity why two
thousand dollars that's what i can't
figure out i mean i
i've done my podcast this week in
startups for 1100 episodes
it's free i interview the greatest
investors and
entrepreneurs in the world if you were
to watch but
10 or 20 percent of them for free you
would get a lot more than these fake
entrepreneurs regurgitating what my
guests on my podcast talk about
and all that knowledge is out there for
free in podcasts
in eb in um audiobooks and in books in
your library you don't even have to pay
for it
so just buy the business books and read
them and
watch business podcasts i mean can i can
i tell you this isn't really complicated
folks something else nothing they're
gonna these losers have no knowledge
they have no knowledge look at this look
at this look at this look at this this
is a knowledge broker blueprint right
they break it up and they'll do
installments for you wow and of course
they that's a bit of a talent they
raise the price of the installments of
course because you know they want to
make sure they get the money out of you
yeah 594 for monthly payments
just uh so because it also tells you who
their audience is right because if
they're dealing with big players
who wouldn't need a payment plan right
so who are they actually targeting
who's actually the this this two
thousand dollar course
for they're not targeting somebody who's
an accredited investor credit investors
make two hundred thousand dollars a year
or more
those are the only people i really work
with as co-investors are accredited
we don't work with civilians as we call
them it's not meant to be derogatory but
the civilian crowd that's learning we
have free stuff for them
yeah watch the podcast read the books
they're all basically free or close to
free right ten dollars for a book is
essentially free i mean you pay more for
you know lunch so that i think that's
overall
i think we've broken down how you know
if you're getting scammed is this more
than the return on investment test
can you get this information from a more
credible person
who actually has business success and
what are they charging for the same
information correct free
or their book bob iger's book
you know mike ovitz's book good to great
all the jim collins books
crossing the chasm there's plenty of
books out there and there's all these
tactical books too
that you can get just on any of these
tactical things and the tactical books
are 20 bucks 10 bucks they shouldn't be
2 000. you shouldn't have two zeros you
should take two zeros off
so it's basically a scam then if they're
trying to upsell you on stuff constantly
you're getting scammed
and if they don't let you pay as you go
for a coaching
then it's a scam i think as well right
like if it's a buy-in to like you have
to do 12 whatever i think that is the
question also
that you're being scammed there's
another thing now they're doing which is
an action-based refund which is a way
they get a lot of people out so they go
i have a 30-day money-back guarantee
yeah yeah this is insider baseball
for all the people who are wondering
should i buy this right they go i have a
60-day money-back guarantee that's what
they'll tell you then you go to their
refund policy
and it they won't say this in the
webinar where they sell you on it they
go
they'll go oh actually to make sure that
you try
we we need you to watch 40 of the
modules jason and we need you to submit
two help requests
and we need you to contact 20 businesses
in order to get a refund by the way you
didn't know that's
going in but if you actually actually if
you watch
80 of the course or more you can't get a
refund
so you need that goldilocks zone you
need the goldilocks zone
of you've tried but you haven't tried
hard enough
in order to get a refund and what this
ends up doing is people
get a refund on day 29 not knowing that
they were supposed to jump through all
these hoops
and these guys go oh yeah well it's an
easy 30 day refund but you forgot to
jump through the hoops um
should we watch one of these neil patel
embarrassing videos
let's do it i kind of feel like we're at
our best when we watch this video
patel i've been wanting to make a video
on neil patel forever it's just there's
too much
there's too many there's too many
grifters oh yeah but look at this dork
i knew this kid because he was friends
with my like brother-in-law's friend or
something and he was like a fan of mine
um and it just it's gross to see what he
turned out to be
but where's the link it's just
these videos are do these people know
how embarrassing they come across like
i was watching a jt fox video last night
because i am
like you fascinated by these people jt
fox reminds me
of uh did you ever see the movie
magnolia the paul thomas anderson film
where um tom cruise plays like a
huckster who is doing like a kind of a
game
and we i you you have to watch this jt
fox one first because
i think jt fox is like the
just the ultimate um
unself-aware grifter in this whole group
like let's watch this one let's watch it
because
he seems like a deranged
individual to me almost like a tragic
figure from some
pathetic death of a salesman oh my gosh
you know what i'm saying you're going in
willie is it like anytime i need to say
something but i'm like i don't know
am i going to go that hard i'm going to
be like you know what let me get jason
on the line
let's have him because you're just going
in on these guys i love it it's so
pathetic though we have to watch this
one it is it
this one is a level of pathetic but
it's oh my god oh my god i just saw the
intro
like that first shot hold on hold on
hold on yeah we have to he literally put
himself
next to steve jobs ho
he split-faced himself with steve jobs
yeah
i mean this is a level of i mean it's
almost it's almost like this guy
is so dumb he does not know how dumb he
is
like it's so embarrassing that he is
unable to unders
like people think i'm embarrassing
because i wrote a book like
about how i made a bunch of money like i
i get it but
did you see this quote next level did
you see the quote
the report says jt fox is the closest
thing i've ever met to steve jobs then
it's
dash steve wozniak apple co-founder
wow wow i mean i know steve wozniak i've
i've had lunch
he's a delightful guy how did this quote
come out yeah steve really let's hit
play
let's go i don't know if he really said
it or not no or maybe he just gave him
50 grand to say
he said to me that you had never seen
someone as close
to steve jobs as me you said they were
very similar
what did you mean by that you have a
very fast versatile mind
and very often please tell me this is
not real
oh my god their totality the way they
should be seen
and not the little specific features
that they have
jt fox is one of the most incredible
people
he is so spirited he's anxious he's
young
he's talking he's encouraging
it's just so brutal i feel so bad that
people
oh no oh no it's steve
and then like free
coaching with six days a week with
world's number one wealth and business
coach
wow how do you get that title maybe
steve gave it to
i don't know but like there are so many
jt fox websites you know this is another
thing
if you know somebody's got a lot of bad
reviews on the internet what they do as
a technique is
they'll buy like 20 different urls
and then they flood the google search
results and try to drown
out yeah the better business bureau
results or whatever
so type in jt fox course or complaints
and um yeah it's uh
it's disturbing like all these videos
that he makes like in these bad suits
um it's just so embarrassing
the yeah i i can't even
oh yeah so it's called it's called jt
fox reviews
coaching complaints uh
yeah these reviews about j
so you can always tell like who they are
because they start using seo words like
they
name themselves a lot in the their own
article
and it's basically because they want to
rank on google so it's like they go jt
fox reviews are spreading online about
jt fox a good review of jt fox
however jt fox made a negative review of
the articles that were written against
them
the truth about jt fox they're basically
trying to capture all that traffic right
so then then it says official jt fox
response to rumors
lies conspiracies and haters
yeah so he's just trying to dodge
dodge everything till it all comes
crashing down i mean the thing is is
that
eventually these guys they either get
sued they get sued by the federal trade
commission
they have so many victims that like
people just they cannot keep it out
out of the woodwork yet or keep it
basically suppressed
but it it's surprising how long the life
cycle is i gotta admit that is one of
the disappointing things is how long the
life cycle they could just keep going
right
yeah a lot of them i mean do you know
the story of like
so all these guys believe in ideology so
that's important to understand
um and it's a lot of it's informed by
napoleon hill do you know who this guy
is
think and grow rich okay so it's their
bible of all these guys
think and grow rich is their bible it
was i've heard think and grow rich
so he was a huckster who said that he
met with andrew carnegie and learned all
his secrets andrew carnegie apparently
said you're the only guy who can go
ahead and
teach all my secrets right this this
book is like one of the best-selling
books of all time
of course of course it never happened
though there's no proof
and when pressed on this he goes oh i
had all the
correspondence with uh this guy but it
burned up in a fire
among the other lies that napoleon hill
propagated was that
he was the one who wrote the uh the
famous words for franklin delano
roosevelt
we have nothing to fear but fear itself
he said that he was part of the
armistice like he's
a famous liar but he whitewashed his
reputation
and all of these guys think of him as
like the guy to listen to because what
his whole thing is
is basically the secret you can it's not
about
it's not about experience it's not about
uh
innovation it's about attracting wealth
it's about a burning desire towards
wealth jason as a real investor you know
that that's [ __ ] right
real real the real path the wealth is
like grit
it's hard work it's lovely there's
amazing stuff i mean yeah it's creative
there really are three people in the
world who make a lot of money
um number one is capital allocators
people who actually invest money into
companies because you get
what's called carry you get a percentage
of the profits so anybody who is
directing pools of capital of where to
invest it capital allocators correct so
legitimate job whether your venture
capital private equity hedge fund
et cetera so capital allocators is one
then there's entrepreneurs
um i was an entrepreneur turned capital
allocator entrepreneurs create a
business
yep they get the equity in that business
eventually the business gets bought or
it goes public
and you or it has profits and then
there's a third group which are just
people who are virtuosos at something
whether it's lebron james or the
basketball
uh or you know britney spears with pop
music
or a chef like gordon ramsay somebody
who is just so good at their
field now those people can also the
virtuosos
have become capital allocators where
lebron james invested in com.com
yep as but one example or you might have
somebody like gordon ramsay start
businesses right so
you you do have this interchange of
those three things but there is
nowhere in this cat this
magical thinking about like you think
about rich
well anyway that's what they all believe
but it's funny to me because
when you realize that the source of like
this like
pseudo guru thing and by the way he's
the guy who like supposedly invented the
idea of the master class and that's why
they all are talking about their master
class you're going to join my master
class this and that
of course master class by itself is not
a bad word by any means but
this is the kind of thing that they go
into they're like oh this is where the
idea of like
you need to basically uh attract wealth
to yourself
think it you will do it it's also why
they think that victims
deserve their victimhood because they
didn't attract it to them they attracted
it to themselves
they go well i thought it and i did it
right because i sold a course
they must be bringing it upon themselves
they deserve it
like famously one of these guys who's
carried it on was asked if african
children deserve it
and he goes oh well their state is
attracting their bad
their bad uh wow
feelings so anyway but i wanted to add
one thing
i don't have a problem with courses that
qualify i think that's really important
or coaches that qualify their prospects
if you say i want to run a high ticket
coaching thing
and you qualify your prospects to people
who have money
i don't have an issue if you qualify to
people who they're not gonna be
materially injured by the fact that they
invest in your thing
i am not bothered at all by that i'm not
gonna make a crusade at taking those
guys down
no i think you're the crusade of
protecting
people who are naive or who don't have
the money for these things
is why i think what you're doing is just
so important and awesome
i i i'm wondering
if we can find the victims this is my
proposal
to you okay can we you and i
form a super team okay the justice
league
and we go after the legion of doom
scammers
and we find the victims and we interview
the victims of this and we get that
maybe they want to be like behind a you
know silhouette and uh
change their voices but if we could
actually hear from the victims of these
scams how they actually work the
underbelly
that's have you ever ever gotten one of
them on camera 100
interview because i'm getting them dming
me it's one of my most viral videos
is a dan lok video of this teacher who
quit his job sunk 26k into this
into dan lok's course and it's it
describes the cycle of the upsell
because first it's
high ticket closer then it's that's not
enough i'm not making any money
i thought i was making money so i'm
going to join closers in black
then okay wait closers and black isn't
making any money maybe i should
go join uh high ticket millionaire or
whatever he's got like a million upsells
right
because it's all about getting people
keep buying and buying in you need that
back end
so it describes the process of this
victim and i call him a victim because
he literally was out 26k
he thought he was bad off before as a
teacher then he was without a job
out of 26k so you do this and these
are really powerful interviews i've
talked to
a family whose son committed suicide
after seriously after he he was a
soldier who came home was looking for a
second
you know career and he got into this
real estate thing where this guy was
what's his that's the worst man somebody
went to war to protect our country they
did
this incredible service and then they
get targeted just like
you know some of those online
universities were targeting them with
the gi bill where they could you know
get some money for education then they
taught them some it thing you know over
the web and they never really got
qualified now they're in debt
it's you know what the thing that really
disgusts me about all of this
is it so easy to build businesses in the
world in the united states there's so
many opportunities out there to do
legitimate business
and that these deranged scumbags
just can't just build a normal business
they have to go prey on people i think
they get some sadistic
pleasure out of taking somebody's last
ten thousand dollars
i actually think that they're like
either
i would say drug dealers are probably
more compassionate in that they don't
want their
folks to go bankrupt right like because
that would be bad for business
right but i think that this group of
people
love the idea of somebody giving them
their last thousand dollars as we heard
in that video
like they they live for this they
i think they secretly enjoy destroying
people and taking their last bits of
money
so i could tell you this i mean i mean
as much as i'm far off
as much as i love that narrative uh i
really believe i've come to believe
over time because at first i didn't
believe it i could not believe that any
of these guys could believe they were
creating value in the world
because of what was so easily
demonstrably true
and you just have to talk to any of
their victims right
um a lot of these guys
have are especially at sort of the
middle of the pyramid have sort of been
duped themselves
so it's like you think of an mlm right
so you think of it victims
there's people at the bottom and they've
been scammed but then like as you go
into the middle it's kind of harder to
determine wait they're making money but
they also themselves were like kind of
suckered in
but they're like hurting people on their
way sort of to the top
i do think there are some people who
have definitely sort of made their deal
with the devil where they're like look
i'm making a lot of money at this i'm
not going to change the way i'm doing
business even though i know it's
unethical
i think there are a lot of people and
that's why i make these victim stories i
try to get them as public as i can is
because
i want to show these people who they're
hurting because what they don't do
they always pin their best testimonials
they always pin their winners but for
every winner
there's 99 losers and when you're
charging two thousand dollars
that's an insignificant amount of money
to a lot or a significant amount of
money to a lot of people
and so that's what i try to shine a
light on is because i think
a lot of these people are dumb
they're making a lot of money for the
first time and they have every incentive
to ignore the incredible amount of harm
they're doing to people
so that would be my take but that's just
you know
i just i find it so enthralling how
embarrassing
they are like they don't know
like how cheesy and horrible
they look it's just unbelievable like
i mean on top of all of it like i could
watch a jt
fox embarrassing video every day it
it feels like almost he's an snl
character like they don't seem real to
me
tai lopez doesn't seem like do they know
that they're like
coming across as like as cheesy as tony
robbins is
they're coming across as like a hundred
times more
corny no they're corny right no yeah of
course they're corny but they're
self-selecting for people who believe
in them right so it's like um
i think before you know how much money
they're making like it's most people
write them off and so they never pay
attention to them again and so they just
self-select for people who are like sort
of like
they don't know any better and they're
just like trying to make a few bucks and
they see these guys and they see like
a superhero who's come down from heaven
to save them because they think like oh
this guy's a huge success
he's going to save me blah blah blah so
actually i think these guys are in an
echo chamber
and insulated from what real people
think of them that's why i really wanted
to have you on was like
for a lot of reasons i think you have a
lot of insight but also because
i wanted a real investor
to laugh at these people to laugh at
them
and call them do anything clowns they
are they're so clean
when jt fox's website i hate to obsess
over this guy but
he his website has him on the cover of
magazines like a dozen magazines that
you've never heard of
i get emailed by these magazines all the
time um they ask you to pay them five
thousand dollars to be on the cover of
the magazine
so they're like sponsored editorial or
then you see these same folks like
they're on the cover of forbes
and you're like is that the forbes cover
maker that anybody can go upload their
picture to
like you weren't actually on the cover
of forbes like we kind of joke about
people who speak at tedx in our industry
oh yeah like if you're a tedx speaker or
you put visionary tedx speaker
or you know any of those things
visionary into your bio you
kind of get laughed at because if you're
actually
the longer your bio kind of the less
you've done
if that makes sense like that's not
something you would
and you wouldn't put a an adult would
not put a bunch of emojis around
they've built 47 eight figure and nine
figure businesses and then put dollar
emojis all over it like it's so
corny you look so dumb and like
you you would not who's taking a video
of themselves in their garage
like i have the number one tesla model s
ever made serial number one
in my garage yes elon is a friend of
mine i was the first person to order it
we've been friends for 20 years
i'd literally have the first tesla jesus
mentioned
but i'm not taking a video like this
like hi i'm tai lopez look and you know
i have the 16th
and more importantly like come to my
funnel and learn exactly how to do this
yeah no i mean angel investing is hard
most investments are going to lose
you could only should only invest money
you can afford to lose
um and you know it's a 10-year process
there is no get-rich-quick
that's the you get slowly and
methodically
um through hard work and lots of pain
and suffering you do not get rich quick
that does not exist in the world if you
do it's gambling
buying speculative socks putting money
on blackjack tables that's
there is no get rich quick you get rich
slowly and methodically
yes you have to take risk but you really
need to have skills and you need to add
skills
and the way you add skills is you go on
youtube
you know and you just watch videos of
how to do this stuff
if you want to learn how to do any of
this marketing
stuff it's all for free on youtube
there's a million channels teaching you
just like there's a million channels you
teaching you how to play chess
you don't or books you don't need to
give somebody twenty thousand dollars to
learn any of these skills it's a
[ __ ] giant scam period
stay away people this is there's no
reasonable business person
who would tell you to engage with these
morons they're morons can i ask you
something
i'm dying to ask you this because i feel
like a lot of things have been
bastardized
by this like self-help industry which is
blown up so much
which has been one of them is like
invest in yourself right they turn
invest in yourself
to mean like not like spend time working
on yourself maybe go to the gym
maybe improve the way you dress whatever
it's
go spend two thousand dollars go spend
your last dime on me right like that's
the new invest in yourself
the other new inve like other new
bastardization
is mentors i can't tell you
how often like that's the tai lopez
thing is like
you need a mentor otherwise you're gonna
fail
no that's completely false all the great
entrepreneurs i know did not have
mentors what they had was actually
peers and so if you want the ultimate
hack if any of these scumbags ask you
to pay them for mentoring it's very
simple
if you were gonna spend five thousand
dollars a month on that what do they
charge for this
mentorship [ __ ] oh it's it depends
anywhere from two to ten thousand
dollars
got it and that would be for like some
ten-week program or something a
mentorship
here's a much better idea for you find
five founders
whose companies are plus or minus one
year
in terms of development of your company
so if you've got a two-year-old company
with 10 employees
you find some other people have
companies you say hey i'm going to host
a dinner at my house
or a zoo meeting um and i thought we
could have like this little circle of
you know me you and maybe we find three
or four other founders
and we talk about whatever uh over a
meal whatever
is uh the most challenging part of our
business and we just give each other
advice and we share a meal
and um i'll pay for dinner and literally
you will get much more out of four peers
coming to dinner with you spend 500 on
the dinner
do it every month that'll cost you six
thousand dollars a year you'll have
12 great meals and or you could just
each one of you could pay the check
twice and be like you know uh
as opposed to giving it to somebody who
has never created a business in their
life
and who has pictures themselves in a bad
suit with washed up celebrities
next to cars they don't own and flying
and taking pictures in front of a jet
like i fly private all the time you will
never see me sharing a picture of me
flying private
it's not something rich people do and i
don't have a plane
but my friends do and i fly private 10
times a year
the number one rule of private aviation
is you don't talk about it
because you wouldn't know that looking
at instagram you would not know that
i mean you literally would never anybody
who's affluent
would never share a picture of their
plane because you don't want to make
people who work for you
uh work with you and it's just generally
it's uncouth
it's just uncouth where did that why did
that fall by the wayside now
the new thing is like the way to make
money is to flex
on people actually it's weird i've been
waiting to show this i've got
flex on right here i put this on just
for you jason flex on flex
on i did a video about flex tape and
they sent me this for free but anyways
uh flex odd the point is on flex off
no point is these people are anybody
who's legitimate
is not going to charge you period end of
story there is no angel investor there
is no venture capitals who would ask you
to pay them
for an introduction to pay them for
mentorship because we have an incredible
way of making money
we invest tens of millions of dollars a
year
individually and billions of dollars a
year collectively
into high growth startups with really
qualified teams
and one out of every 25 or 50 of those
companies goes on to change the world
and return more than 25 or 50 times our
money
it's a very simple formula you invest in
25 companies one of them becomes uber
you invest in 50 companies one becomes
calm and it works out over 10 years we
get rich very slowly
by making methodical investments in real
companies
not courses anybody who's charging you
for a course it's it's
if it's if it's more than a couple of
hundred dollars
it's probably a scam is what i'll leave
it at right
i mean you know you people i think
people secretly know they're being
scammed
it's just that this oh this one woman i
forgot to tell you this
she has these videos they want to
believe they want to believe is what it
is
people do want to believe but this one
woman had these videos on her site
and she was like hold on i it
i hate to go into hour two with you but
i i need you to see this one video
section i got the time okay i'm worried
about you but i got the time don't you
worry about me
so this one woman was taught she used
the analogy of
um man you've been going deep
dating and effing so funny and
yeah and she basically was saying like
on her this is this woman laura
i'm going to hold on i guess it's going
to take a second to find this i got to
do a little search here
because she had this video on instagram
uh let me just find my mlm
post that i did the other day and i took
a screenshot i took a screenshot because
i know these scumbags would change
their profiles after i did it
so this woman's name is lauren tichner
lauren tickner lauren tickner
and uh she runs impact school
and she's dmv all of them want to dm you
and talk to you and explain that they're
not a scam
um and she did this video
that you are when you see this
this is going to blow your mind she does
i think she teaches people how to do
courses
forbes top 10 entrepreneur
so if you're like a 20 something year
old
you have nothing to teach anybody in all
likelihood
but forbes top 10 entrepreneur
helping you launch and scale online
coaching and courses
so this is literally the person who is
teaching you courses now click on the
link i sent you
and please enjoy what will be your next
viral video on coffeezilla
oh my god hold on and you're going to
want to download this one because it
will be deleted after
you publish this make sure you delete
you download this
where's the chat i can't find the chat
real quick oh there we go oh there he is
yeah okay okay you got the instagram
link okay now watch this this is just
next level [ __ ] that's hard to
believe given what we've already covered
so far
yeah and then for her i think for women
who are a part of this graft instead of
doing cars they do bikinis and
yoga so they're like more aspirational
yeah
yeah body and lifestyle so like they
swap out
tai lopez's ferrari or jt's washed up
celebrity
like friday yoga yeah or like a granola
bowl a sahibi bowl
that they're living this like because
that's more aspirational i think for
women
let's see yeah so here let's hear it if
someone comes up to you
at a bar and asks you do you wanna
you know what you're gonna look at them
and just say
go away you freak or you'll report them
to the local authorities
so why is it that when you're having
conversations with potential clients
you're literally treating them that way
and asking them
immediately off the back do they wanna
now think about it this way right if you
what is going on she teaching me sales
she's talking about selling she's
training people on how to teach a course
and she's saying if you're gonna get the
money from them to teach the course
you wouldn't go up to them immediately
and say i want to f you
which is the equivalent of saying i want
you to give me eight thousand dollars
she's going to teach you a better
technique okay of grooming somebody
to get the money just like you might
groom somebody
to f them what's the analogy she's
making
jesus you get the conversation going
okay
and so from there what ends up happening
is you can ask them a few more questions
have a bit of dialogue
acknowledge what they're saying and then
proceed
along and along and along see if you
actually have something in common
and then from there you go on a few
dates after that you might
do the deed and then who knows a few a
few years later you might end up getting
married having kids right
this girl she's got the advice the
killer advice
i don't know i gotta warm people up i'm
gonna boil that frog
well do you you heard of the free book
right
the free ebook yes the free ebook you
give them a free ebook they pay shipping
and handling and then you send them a
little you get them into your first
course
and then once you get into that that's
the reciprocation effect it's the
reciprocation effect you gave them
something for free
the drink you gave them the free drink
you gave them the compliment
you warmed them up right you get the
tripwire and then you get them on the
back end
because some percentage of those guys
will all go into the back end and it's a
lot easier to get someone to sign up for
a free ebook
so you get them into your list do you
know about agora yet
no what's this this is the this
is the moby dick of
fight they're like newsletter salesmen
they're the
like some of the oldest guys doing this
they're a billion dollar company
what all they do is sell
these like newsletters and like these
like scammy looking products they've
been sued by the ftc
for like phony diabetes cures phony
things like this
and they're sort of some of the people
who wrote the book on how to do this
stuff
you ever see this stuff goes so much
farther
than a couple people on clubhouse it's
been happening for years
and that's why i'm trying to agora.com
the agora they almost have no web
presence because everything's direct
response so they don't actually want
anything online
got it wow yeah actually there's
anyway it's uh it's it's a rabbit hole
jason
that seems to never see sue's publisher
agora for targeting seniors
oh yeah there's that i'm looking at the
reddit threads see reddit's another
great place because reddit is fearless
like they're they're brutal they're
brutal
yeah yeah yeah you'll know what people
think we got to do a part two but i
think there's
we there's some collaboration here that
i want to talk to when we're not on air
sure that i think we could
take down the whole lot of them i have a
plan
that is so entertaining and brilliant
that i think we could literally take the
whole industry down like
just boom at once let's do it jason i'm
i'm ready to go i'm ready to go whatever
you want so we have to cut here
and then post conversation yeah yeah
beep
all right thanks for having uh me on
your show and thanks for coming on my
show
yeah great having you jason all right
see you guys